bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous ce matin alors on prévoit qu'au 1er
novembre prochain les hôpitaux de
plusieurs régions dont les hôtes france
et l'île de france seront des bandes et
est-ce qu'il est encore possible selon
vous de se prémunir de cette situation
je pense que c'est difficile de se
prémunir maintenant ça fait des mois
qu'on alerte là les soignants sont
fatigués les soignants parts et des
hôpitaux
ça va être compliqué de recruter
aujourd'hui olivier ferrand le ministre
la santé a mis en avant un dimanche le
fait qu'on ne peut pas construire je
cite des unités de réanimation du jour
au lendemain et que l'hôpital est
capable d'avoir des activités modulaire
et de changer une activité en une autre
qu'est ce que ça veut dire concrètement
est ce qu'on vous demande aujourd'hui
d'être polyvalent oui on me demanda de
polyvalent on l'a toujours demander
c'est sûr que ça vous peut-être encore
plus aujourd'hui on nous rappelle pour
aller travailler dans différents
services autres que notre service
d'origine
je pense que c'est là où on demande être
polyvalent après sur la première vague
les services de chirurgie enfermés pour
ce pour se consacrer aux qu'ovide les
infirmiers infirmiers aides soignants de
ses services ont dû aller travailler en
médecine aller travailler dans le coffee
d'alors que c'est pas du tout leur coeur
de métier principal vu que c'est par
exemple la chirurgie oui c'est à ce
niveau là qu'on nous demande d'être
polyvalent et on n'a pas vraiment le
choix non plus de toute façon et avec l
incidence très concrètement pour les
patients il ya deux niveaux il ya ce
niveau où on ferme les lie dans un
service de chirurgie je reprends le même
exemple
donc forcément les chirurgies sont
déprogrammés reporter donc il ya un
retard sur surtout aux chirurgies alors
là c'est pas réellement le cadre des
programmes très peu pour pour cette
deuxième vague qui se prépare en tout
cas pour le moment est la conséquence
pour les patients sur locaux vides c'est
que les les
les soignants qui ne sont pas habitués à
prendre en charge ces patients sont déjà
dans un stress total
face à cette maladie donc ça se
répercute forcément sur le patient après
on peut pas aller travailler dans un
service de réanimation du jour au
lendemain ça c'est pas faisable c'est
trop complexe et trop technique que sur
les appareils de respirateurs
inspiration par exemple ou sur tous les
soirs annexes qui peut y avoir une
réanimation
on ne peut pas décemment mettre une
infirmière qui n'a jamais travaillé dans
ce service tape dans ces services là
c'est pas possible c est mettre le
patient manger et mettre le soigner en
danger également qu'est ce qu'on vous
demande aujourd'hui dans la perspective
d'une deuxième vague est ce qu'on vous a
sollicité vous infirmières par exemple
pour ne pas prendre vos congés ces
prochaines semaines
alors moi je suis en congé maintenant
pour moi ça tombe plutôt bien on va dire
intrigué mais ça a été demandé sur des
gros centres en effet de ne pas partir
en congés c'est inacceptable avec
l'année qu'on a passé on a besoin de
congés sur le parfum en congé c'est des
risques et pour nos patients et pour les
soignants vraiment nous on nous demande
de revenir travailler sur nos jours de
repos dans des services qui ne sont pas
les nôtres
en plus bien sûr de notre activité
quotidienne et hebdomadaire on va dire
aux urgences on nous demande de
renforcer les équipes de 1go vide parce
qu'il n'ya pas assez de patients ya
patients par mois il n'y a pas assez de
personnel et du coup les lits ferme pas
s'il n'y a pas assez de personnel
alors où on l'a dit c'est campagne de
séduction pour tenter de recruter
rapidement infirmiers et aides soignants
qu'est-ce qui peut aujourd'hui séduire
qu'est-ce qu'il faut mettre en avant
pour réussir à à recruter et donc
multiplier ou en tout cas rendre
possible l'ouverture de davantage de
et en réanimation c'est compliqué à dire
qu'est ce qui a attiré les soignants
aujourd'hui il y avait tout fait hier en
effet une revalorisation salariale qui
doit être faite correctement pas juste
les 90 euros puisque 90 euros a
posteriori mois de mars et à les
conditions de travail il ya il faut
arrêter la pression institutionnel sur
les agents et on n'est pas des pions on
est à là on est des humains et donc si
on respecte en tant qu'humain et caution
nous écoute peut-être quatre noms là ils
arriveront à retrouver du personnel pour
venir travailler
il faut arrêter de croire qu'il faut
nous appeler le à 17h revenir à
travailler à 19 heures on a une vie de
famille on est des humains on a une vie
de famille on a des enfants on a démarré
s'ils sont encore là s'ils sont toujours
restés il faut écouter les soignants
merci d'avoir pris le temps de réagir
sur notre antenne dans les mines ban fc
infirmière aux urgences d'oloron un
simple mari